I'm Mitch Tansby. I'm the Scoutmaster from Troop 404 in Oldman Beach, Florida.
This edition of Scoutmaster Podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
And now it's the old Scoutmaster.
Scouts were coming into the meeting hall the other night for their troop meeting
and I noticed one of them didn't have a necrotrophon.
He was wearing, actually, a set of jumper cables
And I said: what's with the jumper cables?
He said: well, I forgot my necrotrophon.
I figured I'd, you know, come up with something.
And I looked at him and I said: well, I guess that's okay.
Just please don't start anything.
Hey, this is podcast number 334..
Music.
Well, welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast.
This is Clark Green.
A couple of reviews over on Amazon.
Let's start with this one for my book.
So far, so good from Malcolm Dickinson, who said:
make sure to give a copy of this to every Scoutmaster you or your son ever has.
should be required reading to become a Scoutmaster or assistant.
Well thanks, Malcolm. I sure appreciate that.
So far, so good.
It's kind of a fictionalized story of the first few months of a new
Scoutmaster's tenure with his troop, and people have found it useful.
It's over on Amazon as a paperback book and I've got an audio and digital
version that you can get at scoutmastercgcom too,
And there's also a new review of my book,
the scouting journey, from Frederick Lochner,
And he said this would be a very good book for parents who are new to
Scouts- the scouting journey-
It's designed just to be kind of an overview of scouting- at least as I see it,
Okay,
And it's also available in a digital version over at scoutmastercgcom,
Paperback version at Amazon.
Since the last time we got together I heard from Jeff Crump, who's a
Scoutmaster, Troop 701 in Wakefield, Massachusetts.
He says: thanks for all you do and keep up the great work on the podcast.
Your resources are invaluable and you've already taught me a lot about
being a Scoutmaster.
Thanks again.
Thank you, Jeff.
I am always pleased to hear that people find all of this useful,
pleased and somewhat puzzled
Some days. I do sincerely appreciate your kind words.
Well, we've been off on a break for the past three or four weeks.
It's been the holidays.
We're into the new year.
Look for live chat sessions on Tuesday and Wednesday mornings over
at scoutmastercgcom.
Watch our Facebook feed and our Twitter feed for a notice when
we'll be over there having a live chat.
Lots of folks check in and sometimes we talk about serious
matters, and sometimes we don't talk about serious matters at all.
So stop in and say hello when you have the chance,
Tuesday and Wednesday mornings. scoutmastercgcom.
Keep an eye on the Facebook feed and the Twitter feed,
Let's see.
Before I go any further, I want to make sure to thank all of you
who have become scoutmastercgcom backers, and specifically
this time around, to express my personal thanks to. this is a
long list:
Andrea Cupperman, John Ruth, Juan de Penner, Dwayne McCoy,
Paul Isles, Dave Giddens, Darren Dronen, Cooper Yeager, Rob
Glazier and Catherine Leonard, who've added their name to the
list of scoutmastercgcom backers since our last podcast.
I want to also thank everyone who supports the blog and the
podcast through Patreon, especially this week, Craig
Snodgrass, who became a Patreon subscriber since our last
podcast.
You can become a backer or join the Patreon subscribers by
visiting scoutmastercgcom.
You'll find links to follow at the top right of every page
and links in this episode's podcast notes.
Well, the remainder of this episode is going to be
dedicated to answering some email questions,
So let's get started, shall we?
© BF-WATCH TV 2021.
it comes with having things explained to you, and that kind of understanding comes from experience,
And these are two entirely different things. The parent of an 11-year-old is likely going through
most of these things for the first time. They're relatively inexperienced in this
and they have no earthly idea what's going to happen over the next three or four years. We
who maybe have seen the 11-year-olds become 14,, 15,, 16-year-olds several times over,
we can be a little more confident in their resilience, right Where parents are thinking,
oh my gosh, he's only 11.. Oh, you know the mindset, right? But we have a lot more faith in a young
person's resilience because we've watched it work And you can tell parents that. but, boy,
I'll tell you, it's a tough one, because they're in unknown territory. They don't have a map,
They don't know what the next few years hold. And authentic scouting provides opportunities
that most children are not going to find outside of scouting, And that makes it both valuable
And, because of its unique nature, confusing. So we have to have some patience and forbearance
and some understanding of a parent's predicament and do our best to explain and to help them
through this process. And you know, nine out of 10 of them they get it and they become your
ally. And the next email? oh, let's keep this one anonymous too. But the sender writes:
a former scout of mine moved a few years ago and he has finally finished all the requirements for
Eagle, except for the border review. Now the scout master where he moved to has resisted signing
the Eagle application because he doesn't feel the scout was ready Before this scout master
will sign the Eagle application. He said the scout is required to know the names of the members
of his state government, including the names of all the circuit court judges, to know the proper
dimensions of a latrine. I'm reading this, okay, I'm not making it up and tie a bunch of knots.
in a certain amount of time He has sent the scout away multiple times and told him to study
more. Okay, Wow. The writer goes on to say: the advancement chair from this troop has been quoted
as saying that other councils just give the Eagle away. This indicates to me that they are retesting
and they're adding to the requirements. The scout's older brother reached Eagle in my troop
before the family moved and the parents are really upset with this. different approaches
and I'm wondering if you have any comments on this. Well, the first comment is what?
Wow, This is really quite something. The answer is easy. I would tell the scout and his parents
to walk away from the bizarre kind of what I see as bullying behavior of the adults
that are involved with the troop that they found down there and find another troop,
find people who get it, rather than trying to work with scouts who apparently can't follow
the clear policies and directions of the organization that they claim to serve,
and I would counsel the scout to sever any connection with them immediately
and find a troops who, adults, are able to follow simple directions without bullying
young people or serving their own disease degos or their own kind of bizarre idea of what an
Eagle scout is, How a scout becomes an Eagle scout is not this giant mysterious thing. It's all
in black and white. Start with the guide to advancement, It's all right there. It is not
that difficult to do this and it's kind of stunning, isn't it, when people who are charged with the
care of children encourage the children to follow directions and to be loyal and obedient,
and then they exhibit this kind of thing where they are not either obedient or loyal. I don't understand.
The reader also asked a second question. he said: is the Eagle application counted in the requirements
that must be finished before the 18th birthday, or does that age requirement just apply to the
requirements in the handbook? Well, if you look at the guide to advancement, it describes the
process of applying for Eagle very clearly and exactly. It's complex but it's not that
difficult to understand and if you'll read that you'll find the application does not have
to be filled out and submitted before the scout turns 18, but all of the requirements in the handbook
must be completed. So I hope that helps. If you have a question for me or comment on
anything you've heard on the podcast or read over at scoutmastercgcom,
it's a very simple matter to get in touch and I'm going to tell you how to do that in just a moment.
Well, thank you so much for listening to this 334th edition of the Scout Master podcast.
Here's how to keep in touch. You'll find a ton of articles about scouting and many
editions of the podcast at scoutmastercgcom and you can subscribe there to receive updates to
the blog and the podcast by email. You can join us in the vast panorama of social media.
That's right. we have somewhere in excess of 15,000 folks who like scoutmaster blog on Facebook.
We have, of course, the tweeters on Twitter. We proffer poultry tuna's pictures publicly by pinning them
with a parcel of prolific pinners. on Pinterest. You can watch us at scoutmastercg on YouTube.
but if you're one of those folks who just can't face Facebook or Twitter makes you better and you
have no interest in Pinterest, you certainly don't put the? U in YouTube. You know, that's fine,
Don't worry about it. You're in good company. Just sit down to your Commodore 64 and fire off a good
old-fashioned email. Zoom in to the late 1990s, why don't you? huh, You can email me, Clark Green, at
Clark at scoutmastercgcom. that's C-L-A-R-K-E at scoutmastercgcom. Now, if all else fails,
look around your stately manor home and there you will find a bronze bust of Shakespeare.
There's a secret button hidden inside and that will open a secret passageway. Push the button
once the passageway is open, slide down the bat pole and I'll be waiting for you there in the
bat cave to answer all of your questions. By now, it should be abundantly clear that the
Scoutmaster blog and the Scoutmaster podcast are not official publications of anyone other
than myself. No, I'm not endorsed or sponsored by any scouting organization, not by the Boy Scouts of
America or anyone else. it's just me. I talk into a microphone, put the result online and people
listen to it. how about that? huh, And it's my way of trying to lend a hand to Scouters and perhaps
have a little bit of fun along the way. and speaking of fun, before we leave you to this week, here is
our founder, Sir Robert Baden Powell. Sir Robert, Good luck to you and good camping, Why? thank you, sir,
until next time, everyone.